i'll tell you one of the aspects of your
book that i found unsettling let's say
i i've had this experience i think i've
talked about it before on another
podcast
perhaps at the bernardo castro if you've
heard of him
where
it was the middle of the night
i had woken up from a dream
and then as i was falling back to sleep
in this hypnagogic state
i heard
my wife say a word
i don't know what she's i don't know i
don't i still don't know she said or
didn't say but it could have been it
doesn't actually matter it was like yes
or okay
and
then i wasn't sure if she had actually
said it and i started to go
into a spiral of extreme anxiety and i'm
not a person who's ever had a panic
attack in my life
but then i started to feel like am i
going crazy
am i am i hearing voices i don't want to
hear voices oh my gosh and then i
started to think okay don't hear a voice
don't hear voice but then i was thinking
about freudian repression am i now
repressing a voice that will come back
even harder later oh no so should i move
toward a voice what would what if the
voice tells me to kill myself i'm not
suicidal i don't hate my life not in the
least what if it tells me to harm
someone else and
and then i i had to wake my wife up and
tell her
please help me because i'm i'm
i i'm i need help breathing and then so
she calmed me through that the next day
i had a similar panic attack and then
two days later had half of one
then it just went away i even talked to
my doctor about this she said you should
go to psychotherapy to talk talk this
out
but it it ameliorated on its own
then
a couple days ago this is fresh but this
came from your book this is why i i love
you but then i curse you at the same
time there's plenty of talk in your book
about schizophrenia and each time that
would come up my heart would race and
i'm hearing myself in it
where i'm not the type of person that as
you know if i'm talking to you i'm not a
fundamentalist materialist who dispenses
with the divine and so on in fact i'm
extremely open to it and the eulogisms i
get for this channel is that i'm
extremely open and actually trying to
understand like i'm trying to understand
your point of view i'm trying to morph
it with mine i'm trying to understand
other people's but that's extremely
difficult because it puts me on such
unstable ground that i don't know what's
real and then i'm constantly questioning
what's real is this real am i the only
one that's real my fake is are people
lying to me and
and
sometimes just
when i say it out loud it it helps me
through it part of it is like i'm
keeping it in and i don't want to scare
my spouse i don't want to scare someone
else but i also thought another part is
that there's no one else that i hear
talk about this much not no one in the
public sphere and so i thought
one time i heard peterson was
schizophrenic it was turns out to be
false
but that actually gave me gave me hope
because i was like oh my gosh someone
else is experiencing this and then i
thought okay kurt why don't you talk
about it first of all it's curative to
myself second of all someone else might
hear it and be like okay this is i'm not
someone who's
asinine and
so maybe someone else who's somewhat
normal is going through this
castrop said kurt don't worry
this is part of the spiritual journey
when you question consciousness and you
involve yourself in these subjects this
will happen
but either way
what you said which is that you view the
world more and more mechanistically
that's the left brain now that's my
entire life up until maybe a few years
ago because i'm trained as a physicist a
scientist
and that
and that you're extremely
speaking to yourself over and over and
over and i feel like that's what i do
and i've estrude music too for the past
12 years i haven't listened to music
because i just find it to be a time
waster and i'm wondering how much have i
hurt myself by doing so
i wanted to say this to you because well
first i just want to hear your thoughts
and then you can also relate it to the
world at large yes
well
um i think it's not unusual for people
to to have these experiences and people
who think
a lot ponder a lot
philosophize a lot conceptualize a lot
do come to this
crisis of doubt if you like and it's i
mean the first great exponent of this
was descartes
um
but
for his age he lived
a remarkably
ungrounded kind of existence what i mean
is that most people then still
lived
a more rooted embodied existence and he
probably
by his
personality as much as anything was
inclined
to i think he had a schizoid temperament
actually
and why this is important is that
there's a wonderful book which i
often mentioned and we'll
mention again by
louis sass a psychologist at rutgers
called madness and modernism and it is a
fascinating work
and
it it was completely another of these
sort of eureka moments for me when i
read it
because he drew so many parallels
between schizophrenia and
modern culture
i mean even including high culture
and he drew 25 or 30 parallels that are
clear to anyone like him or me who has
treated many patients with schizophrenia
between
the way they
encounter things experience them and
aspects of modernity
and this comes together for me in the
fact that the left hemisphere is in a
way ungrounded it has taken things
taken them out of context
taking them out of the lived experience
of the body
just detached them from what they mean
to us and then said i don't know what
this means
because as it were having taken it out
ripped it out of the context it would
give it meaning
it no longer has any meaning this
induces a sort of what's real what isn't
real the only people who live the sort
of very strange life that we do are
likely to be tormented by this
because they don't see consciousness as
something in here
and a reality that's just out there we
come back to something
we talked about a little earlier and
could talk about a lot more
which is how are you see two things
related co-creating it's neither that
there's just an in here and an out there
nor that it's all made up or it's you
know
so it's a it's a connection
we are beings that can
attend to the world that is our essence
and as
louis lavella 20th century
philosopher said attention is love
love is a pure attention to the
existence of whatever is other another
person another thing
and i think that that is
how we relate to the world that it is
not
it's not alien to us at all nor are we
alien to it it's not that we have to
figure it out
as if it were an odd thing that had
dropped in our past you know um
paley in his um
deism thought that
it gave the image that the universe was
like a watch that some sorry a paley an
18th century bishop
yes yes thomas paley i think he was
and said that um you know
imagine the world is like
a watch you walk on a heath you find
this watch you immediately know there
must be a watchmaker i mean this thing
didn't just happen so he says the world
is like this and dawkins
says and i think very fairly that he is
himself a paleous without god because he
just like paley thinks there is a
mechanism here that is working itself
out he just doesn't think it's god he
thinks it's genetics that there is
something as it were in
a gene the robot that controls etc these
images of control are there in him as
they would be in the idea of a deistic
god i
what i mean by a deity god is a an
engineering god an engineer who is
separate from creation winds it up and
occasionally tinkers with it whereas i
believe whatever is divine is in the
fabric of the world and is not known not
certainly even to whatever that divinity
is it's a process of true creation sort
of exhilaration of that that carries the
whole process of creation of a creative
cosmos anyway i'm i'm probably not
making sense
it's so hard to convey these things
briefly but
shelling in the 18th century was one of
my favorite um
philosophers
was able to express this not not very
easy german i have to agree
but this is at the core of his
perception that the inner and the outer
as is often said in many non-western
cultures they are distinct but they're
not separate and that's a very important
point that it comes back again to the
business of not being lost in
um a context you're distinct
from another
person but you're not separate from them
or sort of
divided from them you're connected to
them but you're still distinct
and i sort of think of the world as
being seamless but with you can go
seamlessly from red to green without
even knowing that this has happened
you know in in a three or four minute
film
the color can change nobody notices the
color changing but it's changed
completely so it's possible to move
along a continuum and and the spectrum
of colors is an example of something
that is not a concatenation it's not
lots of little separate colors it is
simply a spectrum
that can be moved along in such a way
that you can go from something very
distinct
to something else distinct but they've
never been separate they've never been
cut off from one another
they're part of the same
whole
and i think that
a number of physicists that i've
read in my attempts to understand
modern
um
well
quantum field theory actually is the
theory that
i find most congenial to my philosophy
and seems to be being espoused by a lot
of physicists
but in that case
again things can be distinct but not
ultimately separate they they belong to
fields which can be more
concentrated or collapse in certain ways
at certain times in certain places
actually speaking of quantum field
theory
on these
pages that i have notes for you at the
back because i thought that we were
scheduled for two hours earlier by
accident so i was just doing some
quantum theory problems just to get
myself more familiar with it because i
i've been out of the game for a little
while
okay